[Musique]
à mourir devrait-il être ouvert
à plus de 75%, ils ont dit oui à
l'ouverture d'une aide active à mourir
la convention citoyenne a rendu ses
travaux et le politique va devoir en
tenir compte la délibération collective
elle produit des choses formidables
184 citoyens 9 weekends 27 jours et des
débats vifs sur la façon dont on veut
mourir aujourd'hui en France quelles
conditions
pour avoir droit
rêter
[Musique]
ils ont débattu écoutés réfléchis
changer d'avis parfois aussi on va
devoir aborder des questions morales et
éthiques qu'est-ce que la société veut
c'est un peu les montagnes russes
émotionnelles quand même
des débats sur une question à la fois
intime et universel
[Musique]
durant quatre mois le Conseil économique
et social a été le théâtre d'un exercice
démocratique inhabituel le président de
la République a voulu questionner la
société civile sur la fin de vie une
convention citoyenne a été créée
194 françaises des Français rassemblés
ils ont entre 20 et 86 ans ils sont
d'origine géographique et sociale très
différentes
tous ont été tirés au sort et certains
n'en reviennent toujours pas on a tous
cru que c'était un
gars incroyable finalement on est 185
sur la totalité de la population
française oui ça c'est incroyable leur
mission dire si la loi actuelle sur la
fin de vie leur paresse satisfaisante ou
s'il faudrait l'élargir c'est l'aspect
la démocratie participative et même
au-delà de la démocratie du
fonctionnement de démocratie qui qui
m'intéresse qui m'intéresse beaucoup je
pense qu'on sera absolument capable de
construire un avis qui sera solide qui
sera argumenté qui sera dans les
conditions apaisées qui sera
à mon avis à ses proches de ce qu'est la
réalité en tout cas de ce qui peut être
l'opinion
dans tous les esprits cette question
dans quelle mesure leur délibération
vont être entendues par le politique la
convention citoyenne sur le climat a
laissé des traces
pour les rassurer la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a voulu clarifier
leur rôle
[Musique]
notre boussole
donc ce sera pris en compte soyez-en
certains et je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
un parlementaire qui n'aura pas lu
toutes les chaque page chaque ligne
chaque mot de vos délibérations vous
allez être une pierre de ce processus
délibératif le mur nous allons
construire ensemble vous apporterez des
pierres l'Assemblée nationale en
apportera le gouvernement n'apportera le
Sénat en apportera et tous ensemble on
va construire
vous voyez et moi c'est ça après je
crois
[Applaudissements]
mais avant tout rappelle de ce que dit
la loi actuelle sur la fin de vie
[Musique]
é pendant 7 et 2017 co-auteur de la
loisirs bonjour tout et à tous les
citoyens vont apprendre que cette loi
autorise dans certains cas le recours à
la sédation profonde et continue
avec l'arrêt de tout traitement
lorsqu'une personne
est atteinte dans la vie incurable
dont le pronostic vital est engagé à
court terme
on endort
le patient la personne
et ne serait pas se dire qu'on
l'accompagne dans ces derniers moments
pour qualifier pour éviter les douleurs
après la terre nous avons
cette sédation n'est possible qu'en face
terminale quand le patient est certain
de décider à court terme les citoyens
réalisent qu'elle est très restrictive
attendent
dégénérative telle que la maladie de
Charcot est Parkinson était exclu du
cadre de cette voie
je vous dis en parfait
donc se pose de sujet
ce qu'on appelle les actives amoureux
chacun arrive avec ses références sa
culture ses croyances il me semble
complètement anormal que des citoyens
français aisés puissent aller en Suisse
en Belgique en Espagne au Portugal
comme le faisait les femmes il y a 5 ans
ou 60 ans pour interrompre
une grossesse mettons leur vie en danger
on sent anormal
que que nous soyons dans cette situation
d'autres ont un vécu particulier et des
opinions bien tranchées
et je me suis toujours dit que je
n'aimerais pas terminer
dans un lit
sans savoir trop bouger au départ je
suis plutôt contre je pense que avec des
soins palliatifs plus performants il y
aurait quand même beaucoup de situations
où les gens pourraient vivre encore
quelques mois quelques jours et parfois
ces jours là ils sont fondamentaux
[Musique]
justement le week-end suivant ils vont
pouvoir appréhender les modèles choisis
par la Belgique et la Suisse quand elles
ont légalisé l'aide actifs à mourir
j'appelle tout de suite
Claudia Magri et Irène t
[Musique]
donc je travaille en Belgique depuis 30
ans dans le cas des soins
majeur capable et conscient
et un patient mineur ça ça a été une
évolution en 2014
à condition qu'il y ait une capacité
discernement la demande est formulée de
manière volontaire réfléchie et répétée
le patient se trouve dans une situation
médicale sans issue
et fait état une souffrance physique ou
psychique constante insupportable qui ne
peut être apaisé nous avons énormément
de demandes d'euthanasie et peu d'acte
de thanazisme
beaucoup ont entendu parler de la mort
de Jean-Luc Godard ce jour-là il
découvre le modèle suisse celui du
suicide assisté où le patient se donne
lui-même la mort et où les associations
comme Dignitas jouent un rôle majeur
pour faire une demande il faut avoir la
publicité du discernement et pour être
en mesure de faire la procédure la
personne doit savoir un immense plaisir
corporelle c'est fini en charge de
procurer les médicaments les balles pour
les personnes ne réside pas ensuite
c'est un peu plus de 10000 euros
je vois déjà que d'un côté en Suisse on
a une association alors que de l'autre
côté en Belgique c'est vraiment le
système et l'organisation sanitaire qui
s'occupe et qui se préoccupe de ça j'ai
trouvé que le schéma belge était
intéressant parce qu'il mettait le
médecin traitant au coeur du système le
sujet interroge même après deux heures
de conférence les citoyens veulent
prolonger le moment même en Belgique on
euthanasie que des gens qui ont encore
tous leurs esprits moi j'ai dans la vie
des gens qui jusqu'au bout me disent
c'est ça que je veux docteur c'est la
grosse question de la démence
actuellement pour les familles qui
disent mais maman quand elle a eu son
diagnostic elle a dit si j'ai une
démence je mourrai pas retenir et
maintenant maintenant elle elle a plus
sa tête elle pense qu'elle a 50 ans ou
30 ou 20 et voilà et elle le demande
plus et nous on la voit ce dégrader et
c'est pas digne et elle fait une
déclaration anticipée
le débat sur la fin de vie convoque
aussi notre conception morale éthique et
religieuse de l'existence qu'elle
regarde porte les représentants des
catholiques des protestants des
musulmans ou des Juifs sur la question
de l'aide active à mourir
partage-t-il la même opinion
[Musique]
pas que Dieu nous retire la vie à la fin
de la vie terrestre mais nous disons que
il nous accueille avec lui et que la vie
que nous recevons est une vie
transformée à la fin de notre vie
terrestre comme les catholiques les
autres cultes estiment que seuls Dieu
créateur de la vie est le maître des
horloges on ne peut pas décider de se
laisser mourir là également nous nous
accrochons désespérément à la volonté de
Dieu
pour tous si on légalisait l'aide
d'actives à mourir ceci équivaudrait à
un changement de civilisation
quitte à grossir le trait
dès que vous arrivez plus à faire un
match
deux fois 45 minutes et ben vous avez pu
exister dans la société je voudrais vous
dire que la question qui se pose
précisément à vous aujourd'hui
le grand rabbin est une rupture
parler d'une rupture anthropologique
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à présent notre loi
accompagne de la mort la question qui se
pose si on fait évoluer est-ce que
finalement on bouge vers le don de
l'amour
un point de vue pas forcément partager
par les croyants les pratiquants et quel
que soit leur religion se déclare dans
les sondages majoritairement favorables
à l'aide activa mourir d'ailleurs ce
jour-là les conventionnelles sont peu
sensibles au discours des religieux à
titre like moi ça ne me touche pas et je
considère que les arguments dogmatiques
enfin ce qu'on pourrait appeler
dogmatique parce que ça appartient à un
ensemble de croyances non pas avoir
droit de cité dans le débat je suis issu
de la région catholique mais qui ça
n'empêche pas quand même que la loi elle
est sécurisée mais nous sommes nous
sommes des citoyens il a la vie elle
évolue les temps changent alors il
faudrait quand même je pense quand même
mais se mettre se mettre à la page quoi
mais bientôt les citoyens vont faire
face à des mots qui vont les faire
vaciller cet après-midi là médecin et
infirmière en soins palliatifs
témoignent leur messager simple avant de
vouloir changer la loi encore
faudrait-il l'appliquer
faute de lit deux tiers des personnes
gravement malade meurent sans avoir
accès aux soins palliatifs
[Musique]
les familles sont désemparées et les
familles elles m'ont dit aussi pourquoi
la loi elle n'est pas appliquée pourquoi
les gens n'ont pas accès aux soins
politiques ce qui manque en soignants
que nous sommes c'est le temps
à accompagner justement à être
présent quant à la possibilité de
permettre l'aide d'activer à mourir elle
leur paraît contre nature
c'est pas possible pour moi c'est juste
pas possible du tout du tout du tout du
tout du tout du tout du tout selon ses
soignants les demandes de thanazie des
passions baisseraient quand la prise en
charge en soins palliatifs a été
fissuante
ça m'interpelle quand même sur des
choses que j'avais pas imaginer si les
problématiques ne sont pas déjà réglé à
la base c'est à dire le manque de
personnel le manque de moyens le manque
de formation comment on peut évoluer
dans la dans la décision dans la
question qui nous est posée on a eu une
quasi unanimité des soignants donc
médecins infirmières accompagnant
contre le Tanasi
ouais ça je peux le dire moi ça m'a ça
m'a bouleversé
après ce weekend les conventionnelles
réalisent plus que jamais à quel point
la question qu'on leur a posé complexe
et multiforme
retour au débat nous sommes début
janvier les citoyens vont être plongés
dans le grand bain des arguments pour ou
contre l'aide active à mourir avec un
face à face d'étonnant
[Musique]
commune des soins palliatifs
ne peuvent pas très
et si les soignants partent en grand
aussi serrées actuellement c'est parce
que ce qu'on leur demande actuellement
n'a pas de sens pour eux si les soins
palliatifs ne peuvent pas tout et si la
loi aujourd'hui de perdrait pas pour la
DMD et pour beaucoup de Français
d'accompagner tous les parcours en fin
de vie ils souhaitons aussi vous allez
réalisation de l'élective à mourir de
l'euthanasie et du suicide assisté c'est
seulement 2% de l'ensemble de ces
secteur de champagnatiques qui nous
disent qu'ils peuvent envisager les
frénésie 2% ce n'est pas demain
désactivent mourir pour tout et pour
tous fort heureusement mais ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que chacun puisse avoir
son choix à partir du moment où il y a
une loi
de l'envisager c'est à dire que
[Musique]
la ramené à se demander si ce serait
mieux pour lui pour ses proches pour la
société qu'il fasse ce choix là je ne
suis pas le méchant qui vient dire ta
vie de compte pas on va te donner des ex
à mourir parce que tu as demandé des
mecs qui va mourir on peut partir dans
toutes ces théories là sauf que on va
dans un débat inverse moi je vous
propose des bacs
dans deux semaines vont commencer les
phases de délibération chaque citoyen
doit se forger un avis
[Musique]
je me nourris de tous ces échanges et je
pense que c'est important d'avoir
justement ces deux positions ça nous
avait manqué là pendant les deux
premières sessions et c'était nécessaire
je crois que ça arrive maintenant qu'on
est justement ce début de débat
contradictoire avec des positions qui
commencent à s'affronter il y a des
oscillations ah oui tiens ah bah c'est
pas fausse qu'il a dit et puis après
quelqu'un va venir donner un
contre-exemple
c'est un peu les montagnes russes
émotionnelles quand même
les arguments théoriques deviennent
soudains tout à fait concrets la
prochaine audition va replacer le malade
au centre du débat
Nathalie maca appartient à une famille
qui porte un gène responsable de la
maladie de Charcot une maladie qui ronge
peu à peu toutes les fonctions motrices
jusqu'à ce que le patient meurt
étouffait
plus de 25 ans ma grand-mère qui a de
bons enfants
et aujourd'hui ce sont mes cousins et
cousines qui en meurent et je vois
partir à un autre ma famille tous les
deux ans
Nathalie maca a vu mourir sa cousine
dans des conditions atroces avec une
sédation qui s'est éternisée elle a vu
son frère se suicider autant dire que la
loi actuelle est selon elle inadaptée
[Musique]
je me suis déjà pour le corps médical
qui va sûrement pas d'avant avec moi
mais laissez mourir de faim et le soir
malade pour ne pas prendre la
responsabilité d'aller au bout de cet
acte il est dit à un moment donné je
pense que il faut prendre le temps de se
dire que on doit être raisonnable et
qu'on doit donner à
sa conversation
si elle le souhaite de s'en aller
dignement et donc
oui on a des demandes d’état nazis j'ai
une maladie létale l'analyse Jarko là la
question ne se pose pas on devrait avoir
le droit de dire j'ai envie de m'en
aller
clairement là c'est du concret elle dit
bien que oui c'est un besoin pour tous
de pouvoir mourir dignement et de
choisir sa mort là on arrive vraiment
dans des dans des personnes qui ont un
diagnostic vital qui est engagé sur le
cours moyen voire parfois long terme si
on sait qu'on a le gène mais qu'on n'est
pas encore en capacité de déclencher la
maladie ça c'est des situations qui
peuvent poser des bas et effectivement
pour alimenter la décision qui découlera
de nos travaux
mais avant de trancher la délicate
question de l'aide activa mourir les
citoyens veulent interpeller le
politique sur ce qui leur paraît être un
impératif absolu
depuis des semaines quel que soit leurs
opinions les participants sont frappés
par un constat le traitement de la
douleur l'accompagnement vers la mort ne
sont pas à la hauteur des besoins faute
de moyens
d'anticiper cette fin de vie d'atelier
en atelier l'état des lieux est alarmant
[Musique]
que 50 médecins où il en manque 5000 il
manque une unité de son palliatif oui en
manque 10 20 30 les médecins sont un peu
aussi forcés par le système de l'hôpital
à ne pas passer du temps beaucoup de
temps avec les patients et plutôt à
faire des actes tout ça
d'autant que dans les années à venir les
besoins de soins palliatifs vont être
exponentielles
il y a 10%
de gens qui ont plus de 75 ans
actuellement mais il y en aura 20%
dans quelques années
pourquoi parce que c'est les progrès de
la médecine alors ils vont s'entendre
sur près de 65 mesures concrètes à
remettre à la première ministre pour que
les soins palliatifs ne soient plus le
parent pauvre de l'hôpital
[Musique]
en position 26
pour chaque région des objectifs des
couvertures exhaustives besoin et
disponibilité en soins palliatifs pour
100% de la population de la région le
vote et on verra aujourd'hui encore plus
d'une vingtaine de départements sont
totalement dépourvus d'unités de soins
palliatifs
[Musique]
obligés les EHPAD avoir vu personnel
formé à soi palliatifs les EHPAD sont
démunies de soins palliatifs alors que
c'est l'endroit où meurt 20% des
Français
la proposition est acceptée à 91% dans
le cadre d'une sédation profonde et
continue à domicile
renforcer l'accompagnement des proches
de vos découvert
car aujourd'hui les procédons sont les
grands oubliés de la loi
désormais reste le sujet qui fâche le
plus clivant celui de l'aide activa
mourir les citoyens ont planché par
groupe pour lister les conditions qui
seraient indispensables selon eux pour
pouvoir prétendre à l'aide active à
mourir
[Musique]
tous s'entendent pour dire que le
patient doit avoir son libre arbitre
mais faut-il par exemple qu'il soit
condamné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre question très clivante cet acte
peut-il être possible pour des mineurs
[Musique]
et que dire des dépressifs chroniques
qui demanderaient une euthanasie
où l'envie de mourir
la somme à part entière de la maladie
s'appelle le cas de cet homme du
président
mourir n'est pas une façon un peu
radicale de soigner ce symptôme je pose
la question
d'avancer et gérer sur les questions
sociétales il y a toujours cette crainte
de la vérité possible de la ligne rouge
80 à haute si on avait demain il y aura
beaucoup plus de criminalité dans notre
pays est-ce qu'on rencontre cette
situation aujourd'hui dans notre pays
nous en confiance aussi à notre société
pour s'autorer du lait je comprends
d'entre nous gérer sur les questions de
société ça bouscule mais il faut aussi
ne pas faire en sorte que ça soit en
franc pour évoluer voilà
[Musique]
les débats sont vifs débordant même le
cadre de l'émission
au vu de passer par rapport à ce que
nous on va faire il y aura forcément des
évolutions qui vont être amenées il y a
une position hypocrite qui serait
d'autres ouvrir la porte en disant oui
mais on va la barricader à quelques cas
tout en sachant pertinemment qu'en fait
c'est qu'avant inéluctablement sauter
par l'évolution de la loi par
l'évolution de la société
plus qu'un week-end de pour finaliser
leur recommandation
dernier jour de l'ultime session et le
vote d'un texte de 150 pages argumentées
pour créer un modèle français de l'aide
active à mourir
[Musique]
le cadre d'accompagnement de la grande
vie doit être améliorée pour 76
% de réactive à mourir doit être ouvert
concernant les formes d'accès à l'aide
activement rien la convention citoyenne
avait émergé une position majoritaire
celle de la nécessité de mettre en place
suicide assisté et euthanasie avec de
nombreuses nuances reflet de la
complexité du sujet
pour y avoir accès le patient devrait
avoir une maladie incurable et faire
preuve de discernement en revanche pour
les mineurs c'est non pour ne pas
heurter les soignants les citoyens leur
ont donné une échappatoire
concernant l'implication des personnels
soignants la Convention a adopté le
principe d'une chlorure de conscience
après quatre mois de travail c'est 194
là ont l'impression d'avoir vécu à un
moment privilégié grâce à la Convention
[Musique]
c'était génial parce que c'est quelque
chose d'unique dans une vie de pouvoir
réfléchir avec autant de monde et
d'arriver à le faire et de voir qu'à la
fin on a réussi à construire quelque
chose de cohérent c'est une aventure
extraordinaire ça bouscule on se
retrouve avec des gens qu'on aimerait
qu'on n'aurait jamais rencontré
autrement moi je crois que je ne saisis
toujours pas je ne réalise toujours pas
d'avoir participé à ça mais ça fait ça
fait quelque chose par an
un processus plein d'enseignement
au-delà même du thème de la fin de vie
sur la démocratie ça nous dit beaucoup
de choses finalement quand on nous en
donne l'opportunité quand on nous donne
la parole et qu'on nous fait confiance
on est capable de produire quelque chose
et on a envie de le produire et c'est ça
qui est très beau j'espère que ça
continuera et qu'il y aura d'autres
conventions citoyennes pour traiter des
sujets aussi importants et peut-être
difficile avec le même respect moi je me
dis comme mes collègues la convention se
termine mais le débat s'ouvre et on
continue et on espère que nous le débat
s'ouvrira bien évidemment au Parlement
les cartes sont désormais entre les
mains du Président de la République qui
a demandé qu'un texte soit présenté en
Conseil des ministres avant la fin de
l'été
[Musique]